[Music]
who here is a fan of Drake you know what
did you listen to this new album when
when do this album come out a couple
weeks ago no I haven't listened to how
do you fan though yeah it's like his
music so you are a fan of both his music
and him as a person I like when he does
like hotline blink I like when he does
songs like that I don't really like
around and stuff well I don't know I
just like the when he does like more of
his poppy stuff I don't really like when
he um I don't know his last album I
didn't really like that much but that
song where he says let that coochie
breathe I like that song I'm not a how
about this I'm not a fan of him but I do
recognize his
greatness I'm not really a fan I think
you admire I think he's at that level I
think he's at that level where he's so
undeniably like good he's everywhere
dude and you can't escape anything he
does that it's like how could you hate
you know his hits is are it's a very big
library of the songs that he he's got a
lot of hits f i i I'm going to double
down with Bart no you have to have your
yeah you have to have your own
opinion okay um I like that he has a
good face okay that's fair do you like
his music yeah what what song do you
like of
his
Drake I'm Dr I don't think he I don't
think he ever sang his own name before I
think so no I don't think he has a lot
of songs I don't think I like that
that's a song 2005 it's a 2005 that was
a song that song though what name is
2005 oh the name's 2005 oh Drake 2005 he
says Drake o I'm
Drake I'll check that one you guys
remember Cat Williams would just go on
Twitter and have like a straight
non-stop roast on Drake it was pretty
funny like randomly he would just write
Drake's the type of that oh yeah what's
that part that you
pause sounds
like fingers a finger okay yeah he goes
Dr Drake the top of that and then he'll
say something like you know picks up a
teacup with a pinkie out something like
something like that type of guy he'll
just yeah he just go through a bunch and
I would be in tears like reading them I
love those yeah I love just the one of
them drink the type of guy what's wrong
with the pinky out though do you drink
drink your coffeee with a pinky up try
it right now it feels better is the
thing does it yeah what about when when
you put a penis to your mouth you p a
pinky up as well hey that's really is
that misogyny that's misogyny man thank
you man I appreciate that what would you
I think it's toxic
homosexuality well bring it back so
Drake does some cool stuff sometimes at
his concerts right and uh a more recent
one that he gave or or that he did was
was really interesting to me um there
was a fan that went to his concert he's
he's recently been on tour speaking of
Tours Jason chenny is currently on a
national tour 20 C jason.com check out
if he's going to be near a city near you
there it is that's so nice guys you're
welcome this the part where you're
supposed to shout out our shirt merch
though it's a Fearless no fear everybody
everyone fear
everyone care for boys we'll try on the
next
video link bio link bio it's in the
description it's in the description
there it is okay so there's a fan that
went to his concert is holding a sign up
there you know every now and then an
artist might be like Oh I'm going to
read a couple signs and stuff and he saw
one that stood out to him he's like
that's a good sign to pick tonight
usually I'll do something nice for a
lady but I'll do something nice I'll
give away a bag or some [__] like that
right and he uh he looks at this guy's
sign and he goes uh what does it say do
you know what kind of cardboard he wrote
the sign on ah there it is no it doesn't
matter he goes the sign says I spent all
my savings buying tickets for me and my
ex but honestly never mind it's really
her
loss so she didn't come out yeah and
then he goes that's a good sign to pick
tonight you got to do something nice for
a lady I'll do something nice I'll give
away a bag or some [__] like that he
goes so she ain't coming with you
tonight he continued like what the [__]
is wrong with her right and at this
point all the crowd they're like getting
into this moment so they all start
chanting [__] that [__] like the whole
[__] [__] that [__] I like that
that's also misog misogyny man that's
misogyny as well he's pointing at you
though you're so misogynistic little bit
and then uh he goes all right that's a
little aggressive he tells the audience
um but he goes you know what she's going
to feel real [__] up cuz I'm going to
give you 50 bands so you can Flex on her
tonight wa that's pretty that's pretty
crazy that's how we doing it tonight big
dog it's your night tonight and I won't
say it how y'all said it but [__] that
young lady what if what if that guy was
the [__] though in the relationship
yeah he tells the story like that what
if he was a piece of [__] well then
double one let's go damn G's just
like can you imagine going to a Drake
concert and [__] getting 50 G's but
that's why people like Drake though I
feel like he does [__] like that that's
what I'm saying like you know when I was
describing being a fan not just being
into his music but being like a fan of
the person I got to admit like he does
some kind of fun stuff sometimes he
seems like a cool guy I feel like what's
cool about him too is he's into like
what's popping like he'll post his like
basketball bets his MMA bets oh he's
like gambling a lot huh yeah yeah but
it's like you're like oh tight like he's
into like he's really into [__] that I'm
into so he just feels like a regular
person but he's just playing in a bigger
playground but 50 but 50 G's to him is
like if you came to a JK show and then
we gave you a Juni matcha gift card with
a with the tin and a barbell Brigade
protein and some shorts yeah yeah but
that's a good package Slow Roll that's a
lot a lot give a little too much we're
going to have to report a loss that
month yeah yeah I don't do
that maybe maybe a shirt arguable I
think that's arguable but like 50 bands
to him might be nothing but you also
have to know that 50 bands anybody in
this crowd that's something 50 bands in
real life is a
lot money for most people all right I'll
throw in three careful boy shirts with
that and a $20 gift three how about
let's let's start with one one and all a
little slow we don't make Drake money is
that is he notorious for that for like
just handing out hella like he's done a
lot of cool things like that yeah that's
pretty cool like he um remember pay for
everyone's groceries you guys remember
that he handed out yeah he handed out
like uh Chanel or ma bags wow uh he
promised a new Leo couple he paid for
their honeymoon flight to the Bahamas
one time what do dude I I I gave a
homeless guy $5 no you didn't what it do
you I mean like what you no it's okay go
ahead and tell your story okay hold on
man I don't like the attitude that you
just gave me what I'm the one who's
giving you space time did he go to your
show huh he went to your show
yeah you gave him free tickets hey I
can't give you money but here's two
tickets but I'm saying like I give
homeless guy
$5 okay hold on but don't clap like
that you're a good man no no I usually
steal from homeless people I know but
that's what I'm saying no but I'm saying
like he give it's like a crazy but it's
like people do nice things so why is his
thing like super you're right let me
change the article I $5 to home
Jason's a Dr years ago I did it 5 years
ago 5 years you're about do to do it
again I'm going to do it again how
people should write do a write up on
it's because $5 don't mean [__]
nothing dude no yeah it does to the
homeless guy he probably has three G's
in his back pocket yeah
wrong hey some homeless people are more
Rich comeback is bullet homeless people
that's a Donald Trump comeback well
false misinformation that's f f new a
lot of them are richer than we are is
that what a lot of them are richer than
we are yeah dude the last thing they
need is money they need a new brain yep
oh [__] definitely some of them need new
brains with then people that are in debt
yeah dude we're negative 10 G's on it
dude H is man richer than you are that's
very true but do you ever reward your uh
like audience that are do you ever do
giveaways for fans that like come to
show the way that Drake you got to Drake
gives stuff out to people that do
something cool yeah to do something cool
um yeah what do you got to give to your
fans like if you had a fan front row at
your show with a shirt they made of your
face oh yeah what could you give them I
I'll give them um my
shirt that's so nice trade you'll trade
shirt I'll give him two shirt I'll give
him my shirt and then also my pajama
shirt oh w p that you sleep in that's
disgusting like a wife beater Okay but
that's bad marketing that's that's bad
branding that's true go oh that's so
comfortable okay take two I'm going to
give my pajama shirt and also my shirt
that I wore on the day now you go now
you go now you say your line say your
line no that's that's disgusting no
you're wow that's so comfortable wow
that's so comfortable like that oh yeah
but you're not doing it right sounds
fake huh come on yeah do that's why
you're not a that's why you're not a
cool rapper you're not a cool rapper
that's not cool [__] I know okay but
okay let's let's brainstorm what's a
good what's what would you what's an
extra thing you would do for a fan that
came to show and they tell you at the
end hey I saw you on JK I'm a JK fan too
do you give JK fans extra treatment yeah
you I would like to but do you you know
what but I I honestly every time I say
after the show I thank everybody and I'm
so grateful and I tell them that but I
don't know what else that I can give oh
maybe like you in your Green Room you
ask for like um like glazed almonds in
like little bags and you just hand them
out to people small but it's to and
maybe a note maybe like a note saying
like hey thanks for coming to the show
you have to ask them if they're allergic
to nuts oh yeah oh [__] how about peach
rings Brazil nuts people like peach
rings okay you know what how about this
how about I take a bag of sugar right
like uh Himalayan brown sugar that's not
a thing what the [__] is himalay and
brown sugar you made that up you went on
the wrong Mountain made that up okay
take four okay
wrong I don't think I'm I think you're
wrong who said Himalayan Brown Himalayan
brown sugar right and then the J news
people come and then I go um thank you
so much for coming and because I really
appreciate your time I I go and I dip my
finger in the brown sugar and I feed it
then I'm like oh like you're a priest
and you're doing the communion in the
mouth
Himalayan Brown Himalayan Brown yeah
they go suck it if you like and then
they go thank you perfect exactly JK
fans now you know that if you bought a
ticket to Jason Jenny's tour he will do
something extra special for you I think
I'd rather go to a drake
show I'll get 50 G's but himay brown
sugar
[Music]
is